yea-ah I happily boo rappers left on
swerve and steadily shoot backwards
questionable tactics when you die you
won't get greeted in heaven by 72
[ __ ] stop pressing your luck this
desert is tough this the resurrection of
luck I'm on the blast with a ugly [ __ ]
crushing the butt but I don't care how
many kids you got I'm just trying to
[ __ ] finish straight up keep eyes on the
waist
Rawls [ __ ] in my building won't buy
them every day I'd be lying if I say now
listen to your [ __ ] smack it [ __ ]
teeth out now you wish you when you spit
I'm efficient with the flip and the
merch speaking for me I could teach a
[ __ ] how to turn seven dollars to forty
remastered much' I'll be running down a
rap it's like Aston Kutcher
I gave shorty a buck she gave me two on
the EBT I'm in my bag like jake the
snake' TT cheat on the court with cp3
believe it's me hitting [ __ ] wrong
don't give a [ __ ] like I'm eazy-e hit
your baby mother with the dirty dick my
[ __ ] you Nelly rockin in you 36 I was
in the streets Robbin [ __ ] that
serving bread nervous twitch I develop
from promoter dirt I did turban kids 50
calories get suburban flipped gang
assault they tried to hit me put the
murder bid [ __ ] I probably would have
just been coming home I learned from
that moment on you do don't do it alone
I'm getting tape a baby girl I see you
later every kid you ever dreamed about I
gotta get your flavors punctures one
broken jaw that's what I did the haters
I stole your [ __ ] kids right down the
incinerator Oh
come see me at Coney Island I'm the
mayor just got off the patrol thank God
for The Wizard nadir Shah teeny didn't
need a new stomach promoter blue dive
lipping in the cope offer the new honey
keep your mouth shut
they don't know who done it debo in my
way into this rap game [ __ ] like who
wanted who won it's [ __ ] yo yo
huh these dudes fretting on the ground
like they nice and poppin no I know you
homie your life is garbage
the trophy store showing ice and watches
but really Cornett just shut off your
lights oh stop it huh these [ __ ] [ __ ]
just young boys big homies but we don't
bang on camera for gun points
where I live running up in a crib walk
buying like there's nothing say we're
doctors eight kids that's why these
rappers can't run on me I hold it down
stolen fight [ __ ] one on breathe huh
you want Borbon and Beneke just for my
live [ __ ] with the red I beat up
robbery they gave me four and a half I I
scrub the judge at sentencing your than
I laughed back in my cells cutted nickel
but darling I had planning my feet ready
to rock with all of the staff ah but you
don't want to hear that tough [ __ ]
I'm just stating facts sorry that you a
punk [ __ ] if you don't like it you can
suck dick with [ __ ] on the tip [ __ ] your
life [ __ ] watching you stand
stupid flicking off the roof at the
moment a man you need we moving yeah
[ __ ] go ahead I'm home inside plus you
got my feet like I'm wearing a pair of
Pullman's [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll smack you out
of your bloomers
Tim's overhead we ain't rocking a van
Julia mom you got checking [ __ ] on your
feet [ __ ] not saw breath my soul on the
beat [ __ ] stumble in the money's coming
in Thomas out stop getting money by us
[Music]
mumbling me [ __ ] make a rap dude
question is whole career smacking with a
folding chair it's only here I spit
balls that'll wake you up he always got
a new chain cuz this favorites [ __ ] I'll
take it anyway cuz Wayman have my ball
flame you up on a produc the tiger fight
you sleeping wait you want to watch your
girl get a facial [ __ ] Thank You [ __ ]
they had me up north with my ankles pump
I babble dudes on the dog my finger
tongue so I just rap [ __ ] easy like the
staples bottle Oh Bobby you ain't saying
nothing
that's why I came to get him the [ __ ]
out of here bang bang like okay this is
our gym [ __ ] your life whoa that cat
[Music]
laid up with jump jump I sell crack in
the school zone jump I'll play [ __ ] kids
yup and I just told you girl
that's the chip you made up with little
homie get your weight up [ __ ] I did
whale songs with abrupt no made out [ __ ]
move up it's stupid whatever you see me
I got beat up but he was locked up they
talking sweet stuff with white [ __ ]
with eat cup sniffing lines as wide as
the street that's the beat bump if
there's a problem
homie speak up jump I'll go to war with
your building I can give a [ __ ] about
restoring a feeling i spit crack to get
the listen up glorious bomb to crack the
back of your face up I don't give a [ __ ]
about your feelings homie you over there
crying on the grant trying to [ __ ] this
girl so you lying to your men you little
dude really need the rising up the
friend I didn't go to jail for three
years for less than the grant even when
I lie I tell the truth invest in my
scared I'm the nicest book for been to
Japan [ __ ] yeah whether you like
to get not holy I'm gonna shine
regardless yo yo Oh
whether you like you at night homey I'm
gonna shine regardless I've been the
heart and since she was blowing their
gentle conscience now watch it's time to
catch the garden he's just a novice and
he a mess and pig Martha's your [ __ ] is
garbage the people no guerrilla nemesis
gonna win
cuz I love that father get nothing more
than moving this bed huh I'm gonna win
say it again
cuz I'm up at 5 a.m. moving merch get in
the game talk while rock rap is rather
sleep and chill I'm in these streets
from we're giving you speech test in
I'm Seto hairdos can't write better than
me and can't beat my lips yup
with the pennies word up giving you 10
week straight and I pull up in any hood
hop out in any state truck waiting for
anybody I make my own fit your picnic
you should wait your own face the only
thing he's good at is complaining I'm
moving merging snowstorms call
hydroplaning you're the type of game
that stays home when it's raining
goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't stand you
ever cheat on my chest
I don't need trouble in jump shot I'm in
the Pucci clothes let's go get this man
go buy a hat with a monsoon is the
profit that's coming out at the top runs
no set release it down jump it back